now you're in LA crazy drivers all these
things yeah it's amazing it's a really
interesting City some of everything here
some of everything and that's really
exciting part for me I get to see a lot
of the world you know being an Air Force
but it's always great to come back and
see all the diversity it's right back
here at home so I one piece of James and
stay on the children is a once-popular
do yes I love to visit large cities but
I wouldn't want to live in I like the
quiet
fine
for the actual finish bill or for the
Eiffel when they had a casting call out
there actually I was contacted about the
film through our comic art commissions I
think it's a website i was registering
our gentleman named terry who's in
charge of it actually sent an email and
said hey anybody interested and who's
breaking into the business of comics who
wants to be a part of film you know
here's the information so i got the
information that way and kind of
produced for a little makeshift youtube
video and telephoned off from there then
I got a call from Morgan while I was
walking around in the story yeah your
wife of him
no I must have a really supportive
family my wife kind of looked at things
in hindsight as though they've already
happened so she share her attitude was
of course of course you know this is
something you're gonna do she's always
been behind me but my daughter was
really excited
and lastly
well what I say the court thing is done
for my career's give me confidence to
even go out and try to do more I'm sure
that after the film comes out well
hopefully there's a little bit more
attention you know on my art and what
I'm trying to do bring into comics but
right now i'm blessed actually be a part
of a kind of an inner circle with a
great writer named todd is a go and a
fantastic artist named craig russo have
both done work at DC and Marvel and I'm
working on some titles with them right
now mainly the / happen on sat image
comics so the kind of the aftermath of
the film is already kicked in and I
haven't seen a single frame of it yet so
I'm excited to see what will happen
after other people get to see this on a
larger scale thank you
you